but you can't call me a [ __ ] and then
all of a sudden i'm gonna go on twitter
and yeah
get the [ __ ] off the stage don't call me
a [ __ ] i'll [ __ ] your ass up yeah we'll
take this outside
right right but he did some very weak
[ __ ] [ __ ] that doesn't
mean yeah and also like you said what's
what's really whack about it is that
he's taking something serious
and attaching this to it like it's not
it gets really his egos hurt
so he's going to make it about this
whole thing so he wants to attach
this thing together at this point even
thing that's actually really shitty
that's going on in this country to this
guy
to just focus in five four three
two one what's up everybody welcome to
another episode of the
genius brain
we have the returning hosts nick
the ear former mixed martial arts
extraordinaire yeah with a record of 72s
and it's in this 72 and 72 actually
500 records straight even because he
wanted to keep it fair for everybody
exactly
he quit mma because he sexually harassed
somebody in the cage bang
he went for a kiss instead of a [ __ ]
cross and then i got in so much trouble
he did you [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah yeah
watch the tape
yeah send locations so we can go on bait
that's what he said
johnny africa brother johnny yeah yeah
we're going to nick chyna
yeah yo yo what the [ __ ]
nick america baby and of course we got
got t dot riley stand up comedian
extraordinaire
only comparison dave chappelle and
george carlisle
that's about it that's it everybody else
can suck his left nut from the back side
of his ass
wow and actually the third one
jeff dunham jeff he does he does some
puppet [ __ ] it's great
my act is all puppets
which i think his vegas act is fantastic
cool bro that actually is one
he's actually one of the most like
money-wise has made he's one of the
richest comics out there
really because of the vegas show huh i
don't i don't know what it is but like
his
his following loves him like he's huge
what's the disrespect you have for jeff
dunham i just don't think it was funny
talking about the guy with the skeleton
the the terrorist and the the skeleton
and the terrorists
you don't like that yeah an old guy i
don't get it hey kids like him a lot and
also i could see his mouth move
oh can you really take it away from oh
let's oh we're going to talk that [ __ ]
your hand is now a sock puppet go and i
want you to say something
do do it now do it let me see your mouth
uh okay let me see your mouth
um yeah that's bad dude i didn't even
try
my name yeah it is hard but also i'm not
a ventriloquist
so people who can't do always sit on
their chinese acid
china we gotta make an action movie with
you starring
i still think he's very talented that's
just pretty talented no for sure he's
for sure talented i'm not like i don't
think he's funny
but yeah is it made for adults though i
think it's made for like kids isn't it i
don't know to be honest
he says yeah i think he does say crazy
[ __ ] oh really i think so
either he's cussing and [ __ ] who's the
guy that uh that smashes watermelons
what's his name gallagher gallagher
carrot top i think is funny
ever dude i didn't really think about
that for a second i thought you were
gonna step in
i i don't really know any of his
material but i heard it's pretty funny
he does props he doesn't love popcorn
he's like one of the last prop comics to
ever
he like took over the prop comic game i
think he like yeah and he's swolled as
[ __ ] bro the last
comic dude he's on hgh or some [ __ ]
hey you know who's [ __ ] buffy if you
want to talk about a comic that kamal
kamal dude the [ __ ] indian dude oh
that dude's ripped bro
who he's uh new johnny yeah yeah yeah
he's on all the sauce bro yeah he's
ripped
i wonder why the [ __ ] happened does he
think that people don't know
i don't know i don't know why he do that
why is he getting so
jacked he's in the marvel movie he's a
superhero oh is he but i saw the trailer
for it he doesn't even look as jacked
in the middle oh he's just continuing
right now now i think this is like his
sauce boy it's like his addiction now he
loves it he's like yeah i look [ __ ]
good dude
there was a picture on my wife there's a
picture of him i look so good i'mma be
an infidel
there's a picture of him coming out of
the gym or something he's wearing a tank
top
this boy looks like he has garden hoses
in his biceps right dude
like that jacked bro
and he looks like that year round
there's no off season you see the
picture of zac efron
his face dude what's up with his face he
okay let me pull it up this is something
this dude's face looks funny i mean
let's just say this
when i first saw zac efron's his very
handsome man yeah his hands how [ __ ]
his
undeniably a handsome dude you cannot
say he's not if if it was like white
american handsome he is the definition
of
yeah he's the white american and then on
the baywatch movie this fool got ripped
beyond belief
bro if you don't think zack efron is
handsome you're your closet bro
you're gay you're gay i think you're gay
if you don't think you can't be like
that dude
that's real his face yeah this is a face
bro or just some like weekend weird [ __ ]
where it was like all botox stuff
not dog swipe what's up with his face
that's before
zach i don't know what he did what
happened to him well he's probably on
the sauce too
but what this why is his lips look like
botox or something yeah probably that
too i don't know
you think it might be jaw surgery or
something too maybe something happened
it looks weird bro
but also some dudes kind of look like
that when they start doing steroids and
[ __ ] really
what what is that part why why is it
that these dudes hands get so [ __ ]
thick and big and their skull gets huge
why does steroids do that to you i don't
know i think that's hgh i think it's a
different type no bro this looks like he
restructured his face this doesn't look
like
this looks like some weirdo [ __ ] it
looks like almost smashed
both of them bro you're trying to smash
both of them yeah both those cheeks why
would he do this that he was already
handsome face yeah
now he looks like a crazy person those
are crazy dude he looks like someone
drew his face
mad insecurity weirdo i hope it's just
like i hope it's like a jaw surgery or
something
and it's like swelling or i don't i
don't know what it is but
it looks odd definitely the world that
people live in when it comes to los
angeles is not a world that other people
live in right
now like the beauty standards that
people have here are way different
everywhere else like the khloe
kardashian [ __ ] did you hear about that
no what happened she was like upset or
some [ __ ] yeah like talking about there
was
there was a picture of her that got
leaked or something of her in a bikini
and it wasn't like
photoshopped like in the picture she
looks fine
does she look like she's not wearing any
makeup or anything but like it's a
picture of her in her bikini
and like her body isn't
like terrible like she looks fine yeah i
mean it looks cool
but she went on this whole thing talking
about like i don't really look like this
and she was trying to sue people that
like posted it who cares [ __ ] shut up
okay so it's like and the more you try
to suppress it the more people want to
see what it's about
and then she and then she kind of claps
back post like videos of her on
instagram
like what she really looks like who
cares well also like they created that
whole
exactly that's her standard that she
created but that's the thing too like
this
this girl's image identity and value of
herself is only based on how she looks
to the point where a random photo of her
she has to go out of her
way to deny that that's not even what i
look like who the [ __ ] cares dude
your [ __ ] stinks just like everybody
else yeah who [ __ ] cares you poop out
of your butt like everybody else
that's the weird thing too like these
people live i love that
i love that yeah it comes from the anus
sphincter
exactly yeah everyone's got an [ __ ]
and you poop out of it what if she's
like
everyone and everyone has pooping in
their pants story and then she does a
[ __ ] video she goes you think i have
anus
she bends over and it's just a crack
with no hole i don't even have one you
guys are assuming things because you saw
a video from this guy
named david slow from genius brain
stupid you're like you know my name you
said that on purpose
you said my name wrong on purpose yeah
this [ __ ] goop from stupid brain he
doesn't even even know i have
her yeah her brain yeah
dumb jump right here burned burned am i
right maybe i should be a qualmic
dude [ __ ] khloe kardashian but that's
what i'm saying like these words should
kill lamar odom though you know
she killed lamar odom well i mean he's
about to do that
he's about to hit that he's about to die
in that boxing no you know he's gonna oh
yeah he's gonna box somebody
honestly okay i said that trying to be
funny but then i thought about it i was
like wait is lamar odom dead
yeah he's [ __ ] up right now he's gonna
fight you never
guess who's gonna fight in a celebrity
boxing match who just guess
you'll never guess in a million years i
guess okay it's a celebrity boxing match
somebody in the 90s some for somebody
from the 90s
pretty boy pretty boy teen star
mario lopez marlup is way too small
i'm way younger oh yeah that's way
earlier that would literally make way
more sense than who he's gonna fight
cause martin
luther from the 90s that's what i was
thinking like maybe him
but uh give me one more dustin diamond
you're
absolutely right yeah i was gonna i was
thinking that but he's he's i'm not sure
if this is his song he's passed away
greece is
he died like months ago like 72 like
there's 82 on the clock
this drink hey we all say stupid [ __ ]
today huh 782
782. david there's no 782 on a [ __ ]
one there is a seven
eight and a two on this show thank you
yeah i don't think i'm embarrassed for
myself that was good though that was
good hanging out with you wait screech
is dead bro i almost said screech but
then i was like [ __ ] i'm gonna fulfill
my
my [ __ ] [ __ ] on a dead guy dustin
dustin he died like
uh months ago i think i want to say
pre-covered
yeah over here what did he pass away
from honestly i don't remember hey yo
talk about a dude who had a sex tape his
shirt was fired he had a sex tape you
saw his sex tape you [ __ ] weirdo was
he just jerking off
watching that one and uh the captain
america one i mean uh randy couture
he uh i know he casted his own dick for
a dildo
that's pretty cool yeah yeah yeah who's
buying it apparently it was [ __ ]
horse sized it was huge wow yeah yeah he
would have a [ __ ]
giant dong i think i i wrote i wanted to
write how to how to screech diet and i
wrote how to screech
yeah that's that was the idea um i had
no idea he passed
i don't know how he died how did dustin
diamond die wow he's that insignificant
where he
can't find it at all 44 from small cell
carcinoma
is that some form of cancer cancer yeah
what
the [ __ ] that's how we look but in
brighter news
who's he's boxing he's going to box
aaron carter bro
oh i remember what was he like a
musician or something he's a backstreet
boy no
that's his his brother aaron carter
right and nick carter is his brother
that's the fact who's
eric carter is his younger brother so
eric carter had a
he was a single solo artist but he was
nick carter's younger brother
and he was like hopped up on drugs and
[ __ ] he went to like rehab like 46 times
oh [ __ ] he's gonna box lamar odor
i don't want it beautiful or something
like that yeah bro he's also
a buck 25 it seems like he's soaking 33
years old
he says he's six foot tomorrow items how
big
seven foot nine seven eighty two okay
he's seven eighty two okay yeah wow this
is gonna die
his boxing's terrible you know it's not
as bad as when he first started but [ __ ]
man i don't know wait what
what it did happen why is everybody
trying to box each other bro
yeah what is going on and who's gonna
pay money to watch lamar odom
box aaron carter nobody gives a friend
yeah
what the [ __ ] wait i want to see lamar
odom boxing
it's terrible i mean it's it's a
basketball player you've seen them all
fight but what's up with basketball
players not being able to fight at all
because they never needed to who's gonna
[ __ ] with the guy that's seven feet tall
that's true
nobody is they're swinging wild as [ __ ]
he looks like anderson sobo
no he don't but like you know
he he's long he's long as [ __ ] hell yeah
he's 6 10
bro bro this celebrity he's definitely
gonna kill this dude someone's gonna
die bro someone's gonna [ __ ] die when
they do this [ __ ] remember screech did
box somebody though
did he yeah screech boxed um no that's
when he challenged mario lopez to a
wrestling match in episode
in season four of saved by the bow and
they were competing
for the was the name of school
you never watched saved by the bell no i
had friends
yeah it was a very dark time in my life
you know i actually never watched
a lot of i mean this just sounds weird
and it might sound a little racial
i never saw a lot of like white centric
[ __ ] yeah like the stuff that i saw
intermittently was like full house
and um step by step
i believe but my [ __ ] was like fresh
prince of bel air
it was family matters cosby show
uh [ __ ] martin so you didn't watch
the
bell at all they had they had one black
person on the show
remember that episode where that white
girl she got addicted to caffeine pills
you showed me this clip [ __ ]
what are you talking about i i honestly
didn't because i don't know what the
[ __ ] you're talking about you're crazy
i'll pull up some text
caffeine pills yeah yeah and she's going
all crazy and he has to like slap her
out of it like
you're going crazy like as a serious
episode yeah it was but it was like yo
bro she's
gonna dig through the caffeine pills
like what are you talking about it's
just caffeine bro relaxing
[ __ ] relax i don't like her life was
going to [ __ ] because she was addicted
to caffeine pills
yeah so from there on stop doing
caffeine pills
that's the dumbest [ __ ] thing i've
ever heard in my life are you serious
save mom
dude these old these old sitcoms they're
so
[ __ ] ridiculous when they would do
the uh that was during the dare days
remember well that's what i'm saying
this stuff was so [ __ ] dumb they
would just sit there they would have
these episodes and then towards the end
they go
you know drugs are really bad for you
and they would just break the fourth
wall and stare into the camera like
this is not changing anybody's life and
i'm not saving any but low-key though
that's where everybody got their
information from bro
social media was tv shows back then so
weird so out of touch
i remember there's a video this it's
like an educational film and it's just a
classroom this lady talking
and they're talking about sex or
something like stds whatnot and the
this kid raises his hand he's like
teacher like what if so he's like so
what if i have sex before marriage like
what if i
have sex before marriage and she looks
at him and she's like well then you
better be prepared to die
like what the [ __ ] well you ain't wrong
you know what i mean yeah
you know you got to be ready to go you
gotta be ready to go you gotta take
every wish you can to get that boo
every time you [ __ ] it's like some stuff
this could be it
if you grew up in a hyper religious
household like the thought of sex made
you
feel like you were literally spitting in
jesus's mouth
that's crazy that's what it made you
feel like even for me i'm [ __ ] hot
[Laughter]
i'm so turned on right now you're like
[ __ ] whoa
i've never so i never cursed until
like i never frequently curse until i
was in high school
for the longest time whenever i said the
word [ __ ] it literally felt like i was
being pulled down to hell
wow damn look at you now bro hey you
made some [ __ ] strides i never
[ __ ] curse what the [ __ ] are you
talking
about oh [ __ ] so i started cursing
because i had a lot of anger issues
and so every time i wasn't allowed to
release my anger
through words you could stop somebody i
would just say yeah i would either get
into fights or i would break [ __ ] i
would
break everything i would [ __ ] i would
rip you know photos off the wall
start punching the wall or something and
then i thought well why don't i just
[ __ ] just say what i feel
yeah and then i was just like [ __ ] you
[ __ ] this [ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ]
and i felt better after so i was like oh
i said that all right
look at you at all because he's a decent
human being and i hate
you yeah you know i did nick over here
speaking of wuhan nick we should talk
dude we should talk about the tony
hinchcliffe thing that happened recently
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah by the way i
never got kovitz by the way
i'm the only one because you're the
source how the [ __ ] would you get hurt
okay get that pangolin yeah i was eating
pangolins in my house
that penguin boy every day pangolin for
thanksgiving
baby so on on twitter recently this this
thing started going really viral and
usually what happens is when there's
when there's some type of asian person
being disparaged
i get linked to it like a [ __ ]
because they're expecting me to go off
on a tirade or something protect this
man
yeah but you know learn to protect
yourself i will do it when i
when i need to yeah right but um tony
hinchcliffe very very popular comedian
you've probably seen him on the joe
rogan podcast just as a stand-up in
general he's pretty well known
has a podcast with uh louis gomez
killed tony yeah yeah yeah yeah and he
does this um
little show where people just roast a
[ __ ] out of each other yeah like
really literally roast each other
recently daniel rollins was oh that [ __ ]
was right
and daniel rollins just [ __ ] got in
his feelings about she walked off yeah
which was stupid because the roast that
they did it was
the guy [ __ ] up his words yeah it was
he fumbled his words yeah people
understood what he was saying
right and so daniel rollins got his
feelings hurt because he had a dave
chappelle chain on it
what kind of [ __ ] grown man has
another grown man's name on you
like that he's still alive too what the
[ __ ] yeah he's dead first
sure you know yeah but it's funny that's
what tony hicks cliff is known for and
he's kind of like a shock comment curses
a lot says
really crazy disparaging [ __ ] it's shock
comedy right
he has some [ __ ] that goes with it i've
seen some of his stuff and it's made me
laugh
now having said that there was this clip
on twitter from another
from an asian comic i i believe his name
is pang peng dang or dang pang or
something like yeah peng dang comedy or
something
yeah yeah so he's a stand-up comic and i
i think he either he either was the act
before him or he was the one that was
hosting the show
and he introduced tony hinchcliffe right
so
he goes up and tony henship literally
out of nowhere just starts off with you
know everybody gave it up for this
[ __ ] [ __ ] and that's actually how
patrick comes in
yeah whether they're asian or not yeah
and everyone goes all right patrick
comes out with the buck teeth the rice
he's like oh hello
kills it every time dude it's so good
dude it's so accurate his character juan
nick
so good bro well
he's like based off me actually yeah
it's pretty [ __ ]
mouth open and everything so tony
hitchcliff goes on this you know he's
he's basically going off
and he starts doing like an asian accent
like oh soy sauce blah blah blah there's
an asian accent
very offensive whatever very soft i i
saw this
clip and i was looking at it and one of
the things that i always want to do now
because i've learned in social media
is that you can't look at clips and then
kind of judge it for what it is
at that point you have to see what it's
really about now
for me i want to say this because in
case i get burned let's talk about the
stuff that i didn't like
right i don't like him using the word
[ __ ] at all that's like
asian equivalent for a lot of people
that's like n word with the hard
r just don't do that [ __ ] you know move
on from that stuff right especially if
you look like tony hinchcliffe
because tony hinchcliffe looks like a
racist no matter what yeah
that's just what his profile looks like
he's got the teeth of a racist man
i know he's just pristine racist blue
eyed everything aryan brotherhood
so there's no upper lip and [ __ ] you
know yeah like there might be a few
asian people out there that has never
been called this word [ __ ] but just
because i traveled around the united
states so much now
i know that that word hurts people a lot
it's literally n where what the heart
are for a lot of people
yeah so when asian people are going to
hear a stand-up comic go off and just go
get this [ __ ] [ __ ] off stage and
they don't know who tony hinchcliffe is
whether or not
you know his comedy or not it's just
don't use that word that's a crazy way
to start a show exactly if you walked up
and you said the n word with the hard
art you wouldn't get a pass you're not
going to get a pass with the word [ __ ]
that's crazy yeah that's the thing right
yeah that's the thing now that's that's
where i draw the line
now the way that peng dang comedy kind
of put up this clip
he made it seem as if his whole set was
him just going on a racial tirade
against asian people
but i was looking at this clip and it
didn't seem like it was so i went on
twitter and i asked a couple of people
who said they were there
just kind of asked them like hey can you
give me context about this and this is
what they said
they said that it's kind of taking out
of context
and obviously they're going to defend
tony because they're huge fans of him
right i'm not defending his word of the
usage of the word [ __ ] at all i think
that's [ __ ] stupid he could have been
perfectly fine without that build some
rapport first
yeah i mean and they could be friends or
something comic buddies or whatever i
don't [ __ ] know but
at the very least you know it doesn't
seem like that's what it was because he
tried to he burned him on twitter
right so he goes up and then basically
tony hinchcliffe's set
was him irritated and making fun of the
asian guy
because the asian guy was using typical
asian tropes
like you know asian accents to yeah
he was doing a lot of hacky asian jokes
and then all the the crowd was kind of
like laughing at it too
and he could tell that they were doing
it because of the white guilt type of
thing
so that's why he was doing the asian
accent he wasn't doing an asian accent
he was making
making fun of that dude for doing an
asian accent yeah he was imitating the
comic
see because when i saw that clip i was
like this is a weird
like it seemed like a smear campaign
kind of right yeah like
because the the like you said the hey
[ __ ] part like get this
chin out of here i was like all right
but then the rest of it i just was so
curious to see
like why of all people this dude
just went that crazy and just said all
those random [ __ ] like
yeah i just felt like there was more to
the story because because what i didn't
really like to
um with this asian comic right i don't
know him personally
so this dude because we all know each
other but
that's exactly what he was doing so i
don't he's doing that fan and [ __ ]
yeah bing bang boom bop bop so i i don't
know the last thing we need an asian
comedy is just more asian accents bro
like
like i don't know this guy personally
right but one thing i didn't really
appreciate that he did was the way that
he posted it
though he didn't say it exactly but he
knew what he was doing he had a very
clear objective it was close to this it
was
i'm gonna put this clip up and make it
seem like tony hinchcliffe
is a racist guy that loves doing racist
jokes against asian people right
you didn't have to say it but the way
you posted it you did that and
listen you're upset because he roasted
your ass yep
and people were laughing at you because
you did a hacky set in
his opinion i don't know if it's
everybody else's opinion i'm just only
talking about the context of what this
clip is
sure you were upset because you got
roasted by tony hinchcliffe and people
laughed at you
so what you did you took a very real
problem in this country
you took that clip and you made
something bigger than it was
and then it actually was you actually
would have been perfectly fine if you
said
hey [ __ ] tony hinchcliffe all that [ __ ]
was cool but don't ever [ __ ] call me
a [ __ ] i will
[ __ ] you up you would have had so much
more respect
yeah all you had to say was that you
didn't have to go and make it seem like
he was going on a racial tirade just
because it's the popping thing right now
yeah i don't [ __ ] respect that [ __ ]
at all
all you had to say was [ __ ] you tony
hinchcliffe don't you ever [ __ ] call
me
because that takes away from the other
[ __ ] exactly it takes away
from the grandma getting [ __ ] beat up
in the streets and then now people
are going to be like see all you guys do
is just cry cry cry you angle
yeah yeah you try to manipulate the
narrator they told them that [ __ ] in
person
yeah and like go up to him and be like
what's up [ __ ] yeah bro i mean
that's that's the other thing why did
you just talk to him
yeah right he's there you're at the show
with them yeah make fun of my set
whatever don't
[ __ ] call me yeah slap the [ __ ]
taste that's between you guys right
there like what's up
but that's that type of [ __ ] [ __ ] i
don't appreciate right yeah i've already
said the part where i don't appreciate
tony hinch listen
if i did a stand-up set and then tony
hinchcliffe literally called me a [ __ ]
in the middle of a set i'd walk up and i
snapped that fool's [ __ ] neck
period in the story i don't give a [ __ ]
yeah right because you can't you could
make fun of my set
you could not like me and then i'll grab
the mic and i'll roast you back but you
can't call me a [ __ ] and then all of a
sudden i'm gonna go on twitter
get the [ __ ] off the stage don't call me
a [ __ ] i'll [ __ ] your ass up you're
gonna take this outside
right but he did some very weak [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's that's
beta [ __ ] yeah it is and also like you
said what's what's really whack about it
is that he's taking something serious
yeah attaching this to it like it's not
it gets really his egos hurt
so he's going to make it about this
whole thing so he wants to attach
this thing together at this point that's
actually really shitty that's going on
in this country to this guy
to just focus all that anger on him you
know mean it's just really weasely
it's weasley behavior that's the last
thing we need in general from a media
perspective
is to just cherry pick yeah that's the
last one
also you're a dude handle your ship
you're a comic bro
like go to them go to them be like
what's up like you had a problem like go
talk to the [ __ ] he's right
there
yeah why do you have to go on the
internet and like be a [ __ ] like right
on
days that's what i hate about twitter
and [ __ ] is like everyone's all riding
like you got an issue with him go
[ __ ]
[ __ ] his ass up or say something to him
dude like take him aside and be like hey
bro
[ __ ] you why the [ __ ] are you [ __ ]
on my [ __ ] comedy is one of those worlds
too where like you kind of can still
crack somebody i feel like and you
you'd be all right yeah you know i mean
depending on who you cracked like yeah
he was being a dick you know hey joe
rogan i loved your set
yeah but joe rogan wouldn't call you a
[ __ ]
yeah exactly joe rogan wouldn't do that
yeah you know he's a little smarter
about his [ __ ] yeah because it was fun
like tonight
goes hard though i mean that's his thing
he does go hard i remember
i remember watching that clip today
because i was training with jason chen
this morning and we showed the clip and
we were both talking about it and i was
like
something just feels off like something
doesn't seem
like i feel like there's more to the
story like jason chen was like how much
bitcoin has he invested
that's a [ __ ] dweeb
what's his roth ira actually yeah uh no
but like i remember the thing hearing
that and i
like like similar to some of what you
were saying i was like yo
like the chick stuff is crazy like
that's that's a
crazy way just to start off anything
yeah i mean
and then i saw the second part and i was
like this is weird like i just wouldn't
expect
because i've seen tony hitchcliff's
stand up like i've seen him do comedy
and i just wasn't expecting to go like
like this crazy
context is everything exactly that's the
thing that's missing in a lot of things
in today's world is context
we need context to everything yeah
everything that we do we need
context because at this point there's
the way people manipulate and
like just like you said like the beta
[ __ ] like that is so that is some beta
that's some [ __ ] [ __ ] bro like
i just wish he would have handled it
hence himself yeah you know just
handling and like i said i'm an asian
dude
i'm also a comic and i want
this dude paying i'm gonna support him
right but i would support him by saying
bro
don't let that full [ __ ] walk all
over you handle your [ __ ]
don't [ __ ] do that [ __ ] on twitter
talk to him face to face and check his
ass
if it's that big of a problem yeah right
so this is me saying in support of him
i'm not
trashing paying right now i'm saying you
could have done that way better and i
just don't like it
when you make it seem as if it was a
racial because right now people are into
something this is what they call it now
they call it [ __ ] trauma porn
people love this [ __ ] right now this is
this is what it is like for sure they're
making films about trauma [ __ ] that we
see on real life news
every day i don't need to see you make a
film about something fake that's not
real about [ __ ] that's already happened
in real life
yeah because they know it's going to get
views they know the reaction and so
people are addicted to trauma points so
he exploited that and i'm pretty sure
you weren't really thinking about this
when you did post this
to the asian comic sure but you were
just thinking about revenge but there's
a ripple effect that happens when you do
stuff like this
yeah there's a negative effect because
number one there's already this
narrative that asian men are [ __ ]
weak
this doesn't help us yeah it doesn't
help that you [ __ ] cried on twitter
and everybody else like [ __ ] yeah i
can't believe this guy this guy's a
racist [ __ ]
well the people who know the context of
this they also agree that the word [ __ ]
was
[ __ ] uh unacceptable yeah but you
didn't have to twist it
and say that he went on a racial tirade
about asian people he
made fun of you yeah exactly yeah and
you got your feelings hurt
that's all that it is the [ __ ] stuff
you can go talk about that all day i got
your back 100
but now i have a problem with this
because now you're just kind of using
this movement just so you could gain
support
yeah and that's that's whole whack bro i
don't like that man it bothers me dude
because that's whack like
it's wack and you're a comic handle your
[ __ ] yeah just handle your [ __ ]
yeah handle yourself especially with all
the [ __ ] that's going on the last thing
people need
is another diluted story just to kind of
piggyback off this crazy [ __ ] that's
been happening you know like that's the
worst thing you could do man
you're right there's a lot of it just
takes it away it just takes away from
the yeah the real [ __ ] you know there's
a lot of beta [ __ ] going on bro
yeah there's less likes it's just easier
easier to do that [ __ ] but like it's
like kind of
like like even like you hear terms like
toxic masculinity
like there's just all this beta-ass
bitch-ass [ __ ]
going on let me get it like not being
it's not being called for what it is
bitch-ass [ __ ] you know like let me give
you this
[ __ ] dope i can't i mean it's
probably gonna take me forever to find
it let me give you this example
[ __ ] hilarious right there is a
clip of tony hinchcliffe getting roasted
by this dude in a wheelchair
and it was at the kill tony show right
and so they're roasting each other
this is how i wish this asian dude would
have handled it right so tony hitchcliff
this dude is like a paraplegic
so he has like a mic right here and he's
[ __ ] you know paraplegic is [ __ ] he
can't really use his hand he's
definitely in a wheelchair
and this is you know another comic has a
[ __ ] up haircut and tony hinchcliffe
goes
are you the guy that gave this dude a
haircut [ __ ] funny people start
laughing right yeah yeah right and he
goes speaking of [ __ ] that cut what
happened to your netflix special
that's what the [ __ ] wheelchair to
everybody's dying laughing right
yeah and then he starts [ __ ] clowning
he goes well at the end of the day at
least i could get up and walk out of my
chair
so tony hinchcliffe is roasting this
fool about him being a paraplegic
bro this dude in the wheelchair looks at
tony hinchcliffe he goes he goes
speaking of special needs there's also
another special that nobody needs
there's also another special that nobody
needs it's your stand-up special
prop wow that is
how you handle it especially yeah
yeah and you know what he said some
[ __ ] over the line [ __ ]
he talked about this dude's [ __ ] dire
situation being a paraplegic you're
going hard and he came at him with
something 10 times better and he was
ready
exactly ready that's how you should have
handled it right
and you know what tony probably still
would have been burned and you would
have came off funnier but the only thing
you did was say
oh look at this racist [ __ ] uh happy uh
asian pride month
it's like come on bro enough of this and
honestly dude if the guy said it was
kind of hacky like that he's actually
kind of like he's [ __ ] on you but
that's kind of
uh if you learn that it's kind of good
for you in the sense where if
you really if you can get put your ego
aside and be like damn is my [ __ ] really
hacky and if it is
it's gonna make you write better [ __ ]
yeah you know if it
objectively was hacky i don't know i
didn't hear a set but if it was that
and it's like yeah that's not that's not
what we don't need
like i mean i don't know how many years
he's been doing or whatever but everyone
starts off shitty
in comedy it's and you know you got to
like get through some [ __ ] but like if
it really was hacky
it's kind of going to help you yeah and
i thought at the end of the video clip
he was going to like grab the mic and
just start roasting tony hinchcliffe or
something but it was just it just cut
with that and i'm like so
not only did you cut his set you didn't
get to see the whole thing
you didn't give us context about it and
you just walked away with that on
twitter
what the [ __ ] man yeah like you're not
doing
any of us a favor especially that wasn't
the
no i got to go find it i just know that
that's the short clip that everybody
keeps showing and you know i'm
all my my buddies too are like well [ __ ]
tony hinchcliffe he's not funny
is this what you call comedy it's like
guys you guys are also adults take a
step back you're over here going
to the peanut gallery clapping about
[ __ ] you're cheering on this dude
which i don't think we should cheer him
on because he didn't handle anything he
went on twitter and he told mommy
yeah exactly i hate [ __ ] like that i
[ __ ] hate it especially in that world
right
especially because you're a comic right
you have the ability to destroy tony
hinchcliffe you have that power
yeah with your words right because
because tony hitchcliff's
that little intro joke was hacky as [ __ ]
it was
easy pickings for you right he could
have gone up yeah
after he could have yeah gone back at
him yeah made some jokes about it at
least i don't [ __ ] know
do something yeah or talk to him as a
man afterwards the show pull them aside
and be like yo what the [ __ ] is
your problem right yeah slap him up a
little bit or something do something do
so like i mean
yeah i don't know didn't have to be
violent it could have just been with
words no i can't because he's been like
yo that was funny i mean even if he it
wasn't like the aggressive type been
like
what the [ __ ] is your problem bro that's
[ __ ] up exactly like just hear what
and who knows what tony would have said
he might have been like i just thought
your [ __ ] was hacky and
i didn't really mean it but like i was
trying to [ __ ] on you who knows how that
conversation would have played out but
it's like cool bro
yeah it's just handle it amongst you
know just people just don't want
no one handles their [ __ ] anymore you
know he did it the most
he did it the most stereotypical asian
way he did the yelp review
right instead of coming up to the
[ __ ] business owner and being like
hey uh my drink was great can i get a
new one you went away
you gave them a one star said the drink
was terrible and didn't allow them to
fix the problem i don't think that's
only i mean a lot of people do that pro
in today's world unfortunately like i
think i don't know what the [ __ ] going
on i call it the [ __ ] asian boba girl
problem that's what they do
they walk away they go they [ __ ]
somebody comes up to them and they go
how was your drink how was the service
it was great they walk away give them a
one star yeah instead of saying yeah the
drink wasn't that great
hey how can i fix this for you sure
that's what that's that's that's what's
given a shot
give him a shot at first or at least
[ __ ] tear them down face to face
yeah right right i don't know that is
some whack-ass [ __ ] though
i mean that's definitely not the way to
go because it's just easier to do it
that way
yeah that's that's what a lot of it is
it's just accessibility now everyone has
a voice everybody has
uh if something gets a hit you know yeah
it becomes
time especially like in the context of
comedy like comedy clubs or
you know how they are yeah they're crazy
it's raw you're it you're in
a crazy world you're entering the world
of not
non-censorship wild push the boundaries
this is that arena for that place you
know what i mean so
i mean yeah some kind sometimes these
guys [ __ ] up and go too far or whatever
but
that's the whole point is like you're
trying to figure it out you know like
you gotta
experiment whatnot but like to take that
context without saying anything that he
did and then putting out there like you
said attaching it to this thing that's
very serious
that's pretty [ __ ] weird i just hate
that [ __ ] dude i don't like it i don't
like what you're doing like we got
enough problems right
and then we got to deal with your little
fake little [ __ ] dude like it's
it's it's your the problem was the word
[ __ ] it wasn't the other whole thing
yeah you could have just dealt with it
like yeah yeah exactly but that's why
dave chappelle is opening up his own
comedy club
and he's making a seat of 120 people
only yeah and he's
and the objective of his comedy club
from what he said is that i want people
to work their [ __ ] out here
you could say whatever you want it might
not be the best [ __ ] but just put out
your ideas
and the crowd that's going to come here
is also going to be it's also going to
know
that the material that you put out is
not going to be refined
this is what this is this is kind of
what i liked about the safe space
that's what the comedy is supposed to be
yeah i mean ideally like that's
that's how you get to the rich priors
that's how you get to the dude
i remember i saw a joke uh i don't know
if i was watching a documentary on the
comedy i don't know where it was but
it's richard pryor he's on stage
and he's like talking about his his
daughter was like 16 or 17 at the time
and she had brought some friends over
and he's talking about how fine these
girls are
like they're six they're underage it's
like he's made it clear he's like
they're underage girls
he's like man they were [ __ ] and he
starts going into this whole thing about
like how fine these
underage girls are yeah and you can feel
like the audience kind of getting
comfortable like holy [ __ ] like what
they're kind of laughing but it's like
ah where are we going you know yeah
and then he's like he's like thank god
that they open their mouth they could
talk because he starts talking about how
stupid they were right and then he like
flips it like okay he brings you back
like
like i had these dirty thoughts but they
were so [ __ ] stupid to turn me off
blah blah blah
yeah but that he had to work on that
yeah you know what i mean like at some
point it was just like i think these
underage girls are fine
yeah so it's like what the [ __ ] did you
just say
so that's somewhere in some room that
was said and it was like ugh
like this guy's a [ __ ] weirdo but it
became this
but that's that's like you know it's
just like i don't understand
why sometimes people come to stand-up
comedy shows
i don't know who set the standard now to
where
even stand-up rooms are have changed
where the standard is well you can only
say stuff that never offends me
when has this happened right like i said
i'm not making the attachment
to the [ __ ] word right yeah you have to
keep saying that in case people get on
my [ __ ] back now we're just talking
about comedy we're talking about comedy
in general right
what the [ __ ] happened i i don't
understand maybe you were bringing up
the example of [ __ ] dat fan and
patrice o'neal bro that's so
brutal have you seen that i never saw it
dude i'm gonna show it to you i'll
probably i'll show you to you after this
but
dude he [ __ ] him and rich foss tough
crowd was
you've seen tough crowd right yeah so it
was it was and patrice it was like the
bilber uh kevin hart like all these guys
are just
would talk [ __ ] yeah dude like like
break your soul level type [ __ ] talking
and that fans on there and he's kind of
doing his shtick you know and patrice
o'neil was anti
especially on that show doing a schtick
like he just went up there with his
feelings and kind of just riffed and did
what he did
so that fan kept doing the voice right
for everything like everything and he
starts just [ __ ] on him like oh
like like at some point because they
would collin quinn would talk about
topics he's like so he talked about the
iraq war
and then patrice o'neill looks at deaf
and he's like what is your hack
vietnamese mom think about the iraq war
like he just like is
dope like hard like where it's like
he literally has nothing to say bro he
didn't say anything to that [ __ ]
well he he kind of just like he
literally like they're hitting him so
hard bro
he literally had nothing he just kind of
laughs uncomfortably like he got [ __ ]
up
like it was like damn like just like
pump the brakes a little bit but they
were
they had him on the ropes and they were
just i mean if we weren't going at him
that hard i mean
i'm pretty sure that fan could have said
something back just as worse i wonder
why he never did well i mean
he i don't know but i mean he's going
but patrice o'neil was like the king of
like
i mean he could have tried i guess but
he did he was just
it was because also too it was so
spot-on how they were [ __ ] on him
because people know about it and he knew
like it's kind of like when you sit on
somebody and you hit them with some true
[ __ ] where it's like you can't really
like
they're really it's real it's real it's
like [ __ ] like what
they got hit with the ko yeah
like that dude is so bad and then rich
voss starts jumping into which and now
you got
two dudes coming after you hard yeah and
then and the whole crowd
like it was just a nightmare bro i
wonder before it was a nightmare that
fan stepped in
if those comics felt that he was
undeserving to be in that space i think
that's part of it too and he
and he they're all east coast guys right
yeah that fans probably west coast guys
are
it's a different vibe bro like the way
they talk [ __ ] is so different well
think about how wrong patrice o'neal was
and then you've got this guy that came
off this like last
show you know the first season [ __ ]
guys and you know patrice is probably
like i'm way funnier than this [ __ ]
guy
this guy like [ __ ] and he probably
was like i'm gonna make an example and
on top of that like that fan he blew up
but then
that was it well here's the thing when
he did the last comic standing he was in
the very first season
i actually remembered that fan from that
show and i wanted to be on the last
comic standing i remember
watching it i remember when i was a kid
bro i was like oh this dude's funny as
[ __ ]
yeah i thought it was funny too i
thought it was funny you know he was
doing
at that time well because the difference
between him and everybody else when he
was doing that fan was doing the asian
accent
he was doing a vietnamese accent which
was his mom
albeit his vietnamese accent isn't that
great even for a vietnamese dude it kind
of sucks
um and when we were listening to it i'm
like okay cool here's the thing about
those axes though you got to move on
from it
yeah what's your next set yeah and you
know he was kind of making fun of
[ __ ] uh
uh white people and how they would
relate to to asian people with food
he was one of those first people that
did that joke yeah and it was a really
good set actually he had a good tight
10.
yeah it was dope and then he never
evolved from it and he kept going back
to the vietnamese mom accent and it was
always a variation of it yeah
there's no doubt that he was like a good
comic like yeah you don't get to do what
he does without being good at stand-up
comedy there's no doubt
it's like he was funny but you're right
like at a certain point it's like you
must evolve it's like the same thing
even like
like uh def jam comedy back in the day
right like that [ __ ] was hilarious
but a lot of it was like white people do
this black people do this yeah now if
you're a black comic and you're doing
white people do this people too
it's like it's just it's just it's been
done you know like what's going on now
like bring up
you got to bring a new twist yeah it's
just it's just i think that's
just with him he did it and then like
you said it was like okay now what's
what else that's what a lot of people
felt about like um
people who aren't filipino feel
sometimes this way about jo koi
yeah cause joe coy always does imitates
his mom yeah filipino accent imitates
his mom does a filipino accent
it's [ __ ] funny it is funny right but
after i see it in his fifth special
i'm done yeah you know but i think
filipino people they relate to it so
much they get it so he has his niche
crowd but people who are outside of that
they're kind of tired of it
yeah they look at it and that's [ __ ]
funny i [ __ ] with you
that's [ __ ] hilarious it's funny i'm
just saying that for me as somebody
who's not filipino
when i saw his his new special i was
like i've heard these jokes though
you know yeah right i've kind of moved
on and then that fam didn't even
just evolve the vietnamese mom joke
right like i could do a korean accent
i'll do it in my standup all the time
cause i'm literally talking like my
parents
but that's not the crux of the joke
isn't the accent the accent isn't the
funny part it's the character that's
being sure
exactly so he doesn't do that he goes
kraut's not laughing hello yeah yeah
come on guys exactly do better than that
man right bobby lee [ __ ] hates this
dude
yeah yeah why shits on them on the
podcast all the time
i think they actually got into like a
fist fight or something oh really
because they're both like san diego guys
and he goes he wasn't living on her desk
i remember that's all the thing i
remember because i remember in the
last comic standing and like the uh the
hype up video of that fan
he was like he wakes up under a desk or
some [ __ ] and he's like yeah you know
i'm
like i'm really poor you know i just do
comedy as a
and i remember bobby on this podcast was
like yo this [ __ ] wasn't
he wasn't living in her desperate this
guy's full of [ __ ] and he just was
talking about how like
he just didn't think he was funny and
stuff like that and how hacky he was and
yeah especially as another asian comic
who's like i've never seen bobby lee's
actual stand-up
but from when i hear it's not like all
asian jokes and all those
accents right it's like it's pretty it's
pretty wild i hear
yeah but also too it's like you have a
little resentment towards this dude and
i don't know how like asian comic
support
works right like who really [ __ ] with
who i'm just i'm just
i think for me i'm tired of identity
[ __ ] um
i [ __ ] with people trying to find who
they are or whatever what not but now
everything has become
specifically in this country in the
united states of america
other countries laugh at us because
they're like why the [ __ ] do you talk
about race so much in your country
yeah that's something that people in the
uk clown about americans
they they're like you guys always talk
about your race so much yeah where are
you from they go i'm a londoner
um they don't go i'm a black londoner
yeah you know i'm a [ __ ] white
londoner i'm an asian lender i'm an
indian londoner
i'm from london i'm from britain i'm
from this part or whatever yeah we're
very very much race obsessed here
i understand it's because of the history
you know but sometimes for me
it gets a little exhausting too much
yeah it is i just every time i talk to
an asian person now they go
oh so how do you feel about your
identity it's like it's like hit them
that's crazy
how who the [ __ ] are you what's your
name what's your hobbies
what kind of question is that yeah what
the [ __ ] is you guys dude you're always
geo [ __ ] yeah
because you always they always have to
remind you that you're asian
yeah that's like that's fine individuals
exactly exactly what are you about yeah
here's my biggest you're cool too
yeah yeah look at my [ __ ] goopy face
i you you know i'm asian yeah right i
don't need and also
everyone knows i'm asian that's what's
so annoying too about the identity thing
is like because
it's like some people are look you could
be a piece of [ __ ] in any color you
could be cool any color you know what i
mean but i want to start identifying the
dudes that are pieces of [ __ ]
pieces of [ __ ] let's do that cool yeah
you don't even like [ __ ] like all this
[ __ ] like it's so annoying i think
it's really dope that people
are you know that you can are being
proud of who they are right yes there's
nothing wrong with that but you don't
have to make it a touch
of your conversation you can literally
just be proud of who you are and just be
proud of who you are
and represent that by just being you
yeah just be you [ __ ] you know
that's the important part because your
culture will always be a part of that
yeah it'll always be a part of it it's
in you it's part of your story it's
probably
where you grew up you know yes but a lot
yeah dude it'll come out
it's exhausting it is exhausting and
then it's exhausting when people [ __ ] on
you for not speaking up
too much about it right they go why are
you not talking about shut the [ __ ] up
i'm living bro yeah worry about you
yeah do what you want to do i want to do
what i'm going to do you know
if you want to talk about a certain
topic you know some people talk about it
yeah
if you don't want to talk about it you
don't have to talk about it dude so many
people were [ __ ] on
other influencers because they weren't
talking about social justice [ __ ] right
and i got so [ __ ] irritated and there
was this kid that i was talking to on
instagram live and he goes what do you
feel about other asian americans
who aren't speaking up like you are and
i think he thought i was going to be on
his side right and i basically said
why the [ __ ] is it your business yeah
right but do you know these people
personally yeah right they might be
dealing with anxiety
they might be some of the dumbest
[ __ ] you ever met in your life
yeah
i you there's a very odd belief that
people believe saying
something is better than saying nothing
and that saying is false
people who don't know [ __ ] and are dumb
as [ __ ] should say nothing and keep
their mouth [ __ ] shut
people who are smart maybe should say
something who can publix
publicly speak to a crowd very well yeah
those people should say something right
for you to let me tell you something man
some of the biggest
lanes i've ever met in my life are
[ __ ] celebrities
lames like [ __ ] losers dude
just because you're famous doesn't mean
that you know how to speak well it
doesn't mean you're interesting
yeah you're a [ __ ] lame yeah you just
have a [ __ ] celebrity
role you uh you you acted in some
[ __ ] movie doesn't mean you're an
interesting person
yeah it doesn't mean that you have smart
thoughts so why the [ __ ] do you want
these celebrities to go ahead and speak
up about [ __ ]
that is something so complicated and
convoluted as politics
race and [ __ ] um uh tragedy that
happens in all around the world
also to add to that when i see
celebrities talk about serious issues
like that it actually
it makes me go [ __ ] that guy and [ __ ]
whatever they're talking because it's
like
they're so out of like for a lot of
people they seem like yeah
yeah you're going to tell me you know
what's going on you're going to tell me
how to live my life to save the [ __ ]
the ocean and [ __ ] save the planet go
[ __ ] yourself like that apologize video
when i was happy remember the black and
white with jessie pinkman was in it and
[ __ ] and then
he just apologized for every time i let
her joke go by
and i didn't [ __ ] say [ __ ] out of
here bro you guys are all
jerking each other off shut your punk
ass up dude
jesse pinkman okay i apologize
oh [ __ ] the prayer what the [ __ ] the
biggest
statement that celebrities ever made and
by the way i love this woman to death
because she's fine as [ __ ]
she's dope israeli soldier dude gal
gadot
and when they all say it's really so
true
i was like she was in the military i
know i know i thought her name was
her name i was like who's that she was
she a rapper
she gathered all of her celebrity
friends and said hey the world is
burning and suffering
so what i'm going to do is sing imagine
all the people
by the beatles and we're going to make
you feel better one of the
stupidest [ __ ] things i've ever seen
in my life we should do it now
yeah imagine all the people
watch them burn i don't even know the
rest of the song that's it that's all i
know that's all
i was so shocked that they all thought
that that was a good idea when people
are going through real [ __ ] you thought
that your
[ __ ] celebrity ass who makes millions
of dollars
singing was gonna make them feel better
and at least 20 of them
thought it was a good idea yeah because
they were all enthusiastic and they were
all
and look that just shows up out of touch
of [ __ ] that's what i mean like that
like it just shows how [ __ ] not
with regular people you are that's
what's so good about ricky gervais
hosting the
uh no one gives a [ __ ] what you guys
have to say
come get your stupid little award it
doesn't matter
the [ __ ] out of stage bro it's so good
and everybody needed that
you have a platform you have power to
change the world
yeah shut the [ __ ] up yeah nobody cares
i think it actually hurts whatever cause
they're talking about yeah for the most
part dude
i really do i think most people look at
that go [ __ ] these people i've got
messages from people right saying like
hey we're going to have this conference
and we're going to talk about
you know the the problem with asian hate
and it's it's for like these
big big execs can you come through and
talk about this i really wrote back i go
do you know what i do for a living i was
like do you
have any idea what i do for a living i
am not that person i don't know numbers
i don't know stats i speak feelings and
i make jokes and i tell people to shut
the [ __ ] up
i was like you should contact people who
are real there are people who are in
uh congress there are people who are in
political state like
they know these things they can help
they should speak about this stuff you
are
asking me i posted a picture on mother's
day of myself half naked
great picture though that was good yeah
this is who you want to speak to
important people
are you out of your [ __ ] mind yeah
yeah this is what i'm talking about even
me
i am not that point person i'm only
going to speak in the way that i feel
that is correct
that's about it but you shouldn't have
me be there in a place of importance
when there are people who are
smart individuals who know what the [ __ ]
they're talking about give them the
platform
not me that goes for me too you know and
i don't understand why you're asking me
like because i got a like a [ __ ] few
hundred thousand views on instagram
that's whatever
yeah there's other people who don't get
that that are smarter than me and they
know more
yeah go get them right [ __ ] andrew
yang get andrew yeah yeah andrew yang
yeah she's gonna break up don't be
all the time like [ __ ] bro we get it
[ __ ] give us a thousand dollars every
month
please
they took that motherfucker's idea for a
covet though hard they did
they took his idea the [ __ ] that i just
said
yeah yeah now you guys are just using my
idea like it wasn't my [ __ ] yeah
actually came in handy the disrespect
dude yeah these [ __ ] bro
that's so crazy you should go on those
conferences though and just say wild
[ __ ]
just let's just see what the [ __ ] what
happened yo yeah what was that coca-cola
don't be white [ __ ]
yeah don't be don't be so white or
something don't be white don't [ __ ]
just like don't be evil don't be white
yeah and you're like that's actually
good [ __ ] kendall jenner with the
uh pepsi can yeah see caitlyn jenner
running for office
are you for us it's just her and her
[ __ ] loki
kind of fire bro yeah like her ad
campaign was like hey we're bringing
you back she's on there running for
governor
she took a shot campaign she's on the
beach she's like on the pure santa
monica pier
it's like epic music a [ __ ] a knife
cuts dick off throws it in though
dolphin jumps
oh eats it dude got my vote all right
hey are you lying to me no of course
he's lying
i was like the united states of america
you legit got mad i was like dude if
that's the case
he got no she got my vote the real video
though
fire taking a shot at that newsome she's
taking shots on how he handled
the homelessness problem she's taking
shots at nancy pelosi she's taking two
shots of transgender girl in sports too
i didn't see the whole video i don't
know the first like five minutes like
first like two minutes of the video
it was shot beautifully you know what i
mean i was on a sony a6600 you know i
mean with a 20 millimeter lens
it was lit boy and uh and uh no zoom and
[ __ ]
manual focus it was wild but the whole
time like you're watching this
and you're seeing how she's taking shots
and all these people
that we [ __ ] can't stand and you're
like low-key i kind of get it but i only
watch the first like minute and a half
how long is the [ __ ] video it was
like 22 minutes
that's where she put the dick off at
this full episode dolphin eats it
yeah i i literally pictured [ __ ]
caitlyn jenner just standing up there
chopping her dick off blood splitting
throws it in a dolphin eating it and i
legit
i'm just [ __ ] saluting everybody with
that bloody ass hand
okay so i cut off my jacob card
does she really not support trans people
no so she made a statement that she
doesn't think
she don't like gay marriage right so
she's she's not into gay marriage
because she's a traditional woman
bro and wait wait two she's sorry what
there
there's a statement too that she said
that trans uh
girls so boys that transition to girls
should not be allowed to play in girls
sports
boys that transition into girls should
not be allowed to play boy sports
girl sports how about we talk about how
she kills somebody which
which which okay and then she got away
with she should like kill somebody so i
killed somebody what happened to that i
want to know how nothing money happened
i don't know why she always does that
she goes okay
it's been a while since i've seen you
okay like when did you pick that up
she's mr garrison bro yeah yeah for real
she saw she saw a [ __ ] south park and
i was like i'm gonna just lean into that
and she didn't even know that they're
[ __ ] based off her and [ __ ] you know
yeah so yeah
hold on let's back this up for a second
there's a lot going on so this this
woman
who is trans right trans
doesn't believe in gay marriage thinks
that gay marriage is an abomination
because because she's a traditional
woman who she's a woman that's
into women so technically she's a
lesbian so she doesn't even believe in
her own relationships
what the [ __ ] is going on right now it's
called she's a traditional woman
that's a lesbian wait yeah she's
anti-gay marriage
but she's a woman who likes still likes
women
so that makes her a lesbian so she's not
even into her own [ __ ]
it's called being insane
[Applause]
i'm trying to pick the pieces to create
this puzzle in this tapestry
and none of the [ __ ] puzzle is
fitting into each other
also said that trans so boys that
transition to girls should not
be able to play sports girls sports
which controversial issue
if you say that as like if one of us
said that we're considered
transphobic like you are a piece of [ __ ]
oh could you ever yeah
because it should be like there's this
thing now where it's like if you're a
boy transition to a girl we're supposed
to say like that's definitely a girl so
he should be able to wrestle with girls
or he should be able to play soccer with
girls or
or weight lift with girls well you say
that obviously he [ __ ] up your daughter
yeah exactly that's that's what she
[ __ ] up your daughter but even see that
even saying that is like transfo that's
why when he when she said it or caitlyn
jenner said it
i was laughing because i was like what
what are they gonna do now because it's
like
the queen the person that started this
whole [ __ ] with the vogue [ __ ]
uh transgender woman hate bags
off her dick into the ocean and then
i'll [ __ ] die
i feel like the whole trans community
didn't really [ __ ] with her at the
beginning like they kind of represented
her
they kind of resented her you know
because she had such a like privilege
going into it and she didn't really get
like the real maybe experience
maybe the real trans community did but
she was so
celebrated by everyone i probably that
wasn't trans honestly
you're probably right though probably
the real [ __ ] were like we have
to invite somebody who is trans
sexual to talk about we have topics
because i don't i don't think i
personally know anybody who's trans
well i don't know anybody at all i know
somebody and they [ __ ] don't [ __ ]
with this fool
you know well i mean it was very weird
too and i'm not sure if other people
agree with this and
this might be insensitive but when she
won woman of the year award
that was like who who gives you a woman
of the year
and first of all you have been a woman a
year or two there are so many
who've been a woman their whole [ __ ]
life that i could think of that probably
deserves that award
for sure more than you i saw a funny
joke it was like it took a man with like
say no more
[ __ ] kill somebody on pch the guys is
a [ __ ] olympic uh this woman is a
[ __ ] olympic athlete
yeah an olympic athlete she becomes
hanging out [ __ ]
kim kardashian's mom anti-gay but it is
that's so crazy yeah what in the hell is
going on that's hard to track huh like
if you were to put all her like
that whole family is [ __ ] up they're
that's what i'm saying it's like that's
that family's a disease bro yeah they're
like a attention disease like a virus
bro like you should say
people buying in though bro yeah they
buy in but it's just fun because it's
because it's like
it's just the cheap baseline thing to
get it's like the mcdonald's of like
humanity you know it yeah people in the
transgender community
cannot [ __ ] with her at all absolutely
not they must they must [ __ ] hate her
i'm sure they do
i'm sure i would assume they do but i
don't know i
i we gotta talk to we gotta do some
[ __ ] on the street reporting
that's crazy too it's like come on what
the [ __ ] i'ma [ __ ] up a little bit you
know but also you're a piece of [ __ ]
yeah how dare you sorry sorry sir i mean
man my bad
damn bro but that's an elliott yeah
elliott page i bet i bet ellie paige
don't [ __ ] with caitlyn
no but it seems like nobody [ __ ] okay i
don't know bro to be honest is there
anything
yeah jenner i almost said kardashian but
like yo like
it seems like her running for governor
everyone's like yo [ __ ] that
[ __ ] that because what what is she going
to bring that's better than [ __ ]
gavin newsom
i think they're trying to get gavin
newsom out bro yeah bro let's get rid of
that folks
joshua fabia grizzly bear you see the
commercial the guy with the grizzly bear
no
there's a i thought it was a joke i was
like this can't be real it's like this
guy's like i'm gonna
i'm like a bear i'm gonna eat i'm a bird
and it's like literally it ends with him
walking with a big ass grizzly bear i
was like this is a joke
it literally looks like the cornea [ __ ]
but it knew it was like rawr there was
even like a rare in the video this is
what i'm saying man this literally goes
back to what i was talking about how
celebrities are not of this world
but they think that they understand what
the regular person is going through and
you
[ __ ] don't you don't know you've been
so detached especially people born in
wealth
and that jenner family that kardashian
family you were born in wealth
you don't know anything about regular
people
like even kim kardashian posting this
[ __ ] she goes like asian people are
people too
no [ __ ] [ __ ] like why did you see that
she was like hashtag
yeah like [ __ ] like that it's like oh my
god like i know you think that you're
fired
she forgot to add a question mark yeah
asian rpg like i didn't know that that
was the cause that we're behind like
we're not even
we're not even like considered human
beings we're like yeah yeah we are human
beings
yeah bro that's so crazy but that's what
i'm saying this is how detached
they are man yo that's so funny oh my
god kim kardashian man
shout out to kim k man shout out to kick
heart pepsi can thing
the wrong
her [ __ ] butt implants were just so
ridiculous yeah
like you're already this beautiful
beautiful woman
and then you let you don't need that you
let other people tell you
how dictate how beautiful you are and it
[ __ ] you up in the head man
listen i'm not telling a woman what to
do with their body your body is your
[ __ ] body but just don't get ass
implanted yeah
just don't let them don't don't do that
they don't do blue bridges do [ __ ]
hip throttles
honestly they look bad yeah they look
good because kim's legs are [ __ ] this
they're too thin
and their ass and her ass is [ __ ]
this big that looks great does it make
sense it looks crazy
like the this beauty standard that women
are said to is just too ridiculous now
in this city like you have to look this
way or you're not considered all the
girls
in like west hollywood and [ __ ] they all
kind of look the same they look exactly
the same the same lipsticks their
eyelashes are
four feet out you know i mean like and
just that's the thing i really don't
like about la like i like a lot of
things about la but that like whole
vanity thing is so gross
yeah like the superficial aspect of it
is like oh yeah okay
because then we gotta look at ourselves
and be like what are we getting like i'm
telling you
all these other cities not these huge
metropolitan cities i'm talking about
outside of los angeles new york whatever
regular folk they don't give a [ __ ]
about the [ __ ] they don't give a [ __ ]
they are the majority of this world and
you you walk into this city and then you
see it all around it's like none of
every single one of you have forgot what
it's like to be a human [ __ ] being
yeah right and what humans look like and
what people should really care about
yeah it's dumb and then you're holding
on to this idea of beauty that will
never last you you are going to
[ __ ] die and be in this dirt just
like me yeah nobody's gonna give a [ __ ]
about how hot you are
especially when they're walking around
in l.a and [ __ ] with their lips all
crazy drinking it's not even just women
too by the way it's
these dudes they're getting botox now
they get their lips done too
it's like you look [ __ ] stupid guy
people look crazy i'm trying to get some
bowties i don't understand
people people walk like look in the
mirror and don't go like i look like a
[ __ ] lunatic
yeah they're just they're just some
things in l.a that is so well
that are unacceptable you know
good lord yeah that sucks man imagine
like feeling that way
that would be really rough that is rough
that's a miserable existence for sure
before we wrap up this podcast we do
have to get on to the last topic which
is uh joe budden
so joe budden if you guys want to talk
about this
show that's joe budden bro buddy joey
from cohost i'm right here i'm available
monday through wednesday you know please
do you can't get through a story without
stuttering you [ __ ] yeah
anyways speaking of feeling nicer to me
though
yeah yeah i don't think so i really
don't think so
joe budden is like can't defend a
guillotine though damn
[ __ ] you don't you don't know joe budden
like that [ __ ] what's up joe button
all right you right here you're right i
was talking spicy all right what's that
spice
okay so joe budden is known for his very
very popular podcast the joe budden
podcast
his name and everything else he has two
co-hosts he has rory and maul
right uh i listen to the podcast
occasionally here and there joe budd is
somebody who could
who can [ __ ] talk to a doorknob
that's that's his skill
more than more so than being a rapper a
battle rapper
uh industry rapper or whatever his best
skill is his ability to talk about
anything which is why his podcast does
really well he had this whole beef and
drama with spotify not offering him
enough money
took his [ __ ] off the spotify platform
there was that whole issue that he had
and you know he's very good at
sensationalizing his personal beasts or
whatever
not too long ago him and the the cast
members said that
they were going to put the podcast on
hiatus because they were to go through
therapy
never ever heard of myself a bunch of
three heterosexual dudes saying
we need to go therapy together never in
my life yeah yeah
is what it is i mean i'm not a part of
this la world i don't know what's going
on
i thought you guys just [ __ ] duke it
out and then you know hash out your
differences yeah so they decided to go
to therapy or whatever
turns out didn't work out well for them
rory and maul are now fired off the
podcast
so now it's just joe budden and which is
kind of crazy
because i guess the dispute is that
rory and maul feel like they deserve a
bit of joe budden's legacy
um and kind of what he built with them
with the podcast and i think it's a
fight over equity
like i deserve equity in this company
how long have they been doing the
podcast within
six years yeah six years
and he was paying him though he was
paying them a paycheck yeah
and they wanted like a slice of the i
think they wanted this is a weird
topic right because a lot of companies
go through this right
depending on what what the situation is
right there are people who like joe
budden who has
built up his name built up everything
else and so he decides to pay people
like cast members right
there's other people who start a podcast
and they go i'll give everybody a piece
of this and you guys own it all equally
um you don't see that a lot
it's usually not that not the case
unless the people bring something to the
podcast that allow the podcast to grow
if not then they just kind of cast it
out it's like building a tv show and
saying
hey i'm going to pay you guys out this
is what it is right
if the podcast makes money
y'all need to watch this a little more
these people are going to need the
paychecks please please yo help us out a
bit
where does that might be
[Laughter]
um and it depends on what people feel
about it some people are like okay well
joe bunning built his name joe budden
was a huge name rory
nobody knew who the [ __ ] they were right
and so he brings his friends on and he
chops up has his podcast
and they get a paycheck from it it's a
good deal yeah
if they're able to make a living off
this dude's podcast and they're
they're just showing up you know i feel
like a paycheck
is pretty fair but if you're we know
some people that have
podcast situations where they do other
things like they edit they produce or
they do
other pieces to the production they're
pivotal
for the [ __ ] podcast making money you
know some some guys do ads
they reach out and they do all this
other stuff so i understand if they have
a cut in that
that's different most people don't even
do that dude yeah they like produce
producers they get paid out they go hey
this is your salary
you'll get paid whatever uh 50 60 70 80k
a month to produce this and this is what
it is
yeah and right for a lot of people it's
like that's kind of nice that's [ __ ]
solid yeah so it's like
i mean for me let's say i was a part of
joe budden's podcast right
i know i don't really have a big of pull
as him right
well let's say like i didn't even have
this right i was just the comic and
um nobody knew who the [ __ ] i was so you
had like 10k followers or
[ __ ] even less i said 5k followers right
you know who the [ __ ] i am right and i
got brought on and joe budden was like
hey i'm gonna pay you to be a cast
member
i would never in my mind think that this
is just my opinion other people might
think differently
i wouldn't want to own a piece of his
stuff because i know joe button built
his name off of the stuff that he did
and people are watching because of joe
button
and i'm in addition that somebody else
could have you bring value
i bring value but it's a i didn't bring
but you're also getting paid for that
i'm getting paid exactly
so it's like that sounds that sounds
like a fair deal yeah i think like okay
if i'm if you're making millions of
dollars on this podcast
yeah i wouldn't mind a paycheck sure but
i don't think i would step in and feel
like i own a piece of that company
here's a great example of that right and
i'm not saying it's just from my side
we started up a show called just kidding
news i didn't i don't own any bit of
just kidding news but i've been on just
kidding news since day one and i've
actually helped build that channel in
terms of like
format how to make jokes everything up
this is this is what i did yeah right
here's the thing
i didn't put up money to build it i
didn't cast people i didn't produce it
i just came into cain as a cast member i
never asked for a piece of jk news you
know why because i don't deserve it
they built it up with their name their
brand they did the groundwork i just
came in and i made jokes and i
did the comic stuff yeah yeah do i feel
like i owned a piece of that company
never in my life yeah i would never
think that because
i played my role as a cast member and i
got paid for it yeah and i feel like
that's what i do
that sounds fair so a lot of the times
what happens when this you know people
kind of get big-headed they're entitled
they get entitled to somebody else's
glory
well joe budden has this is just my
opinion about it right i don't know if i
agree with how joe budden went about it
yeah what did he do he just went harder
he fired him on like the pocket like you
fired them on the podcast and then
and then for you to watch it i think he
put it behind a paywall yep it's
pretty bad dude pay for this patreon
yeah you want to see it
pay for it pay up pay up so let me just
read this [ __ ] in an episode of his
podcast that appeared on multiple
platforms on wednesday fast forward
um button and nedesca alexis the letter
of
it's all about timing of the universe
button said around 19 minutes into the
episode which he since noted well now
live on patreon
will now be live on patreon uh
unfortunately for ak when i left complex
that gave him more leverage and he knows
that
that stick that stick up time everything
joe wanted i wanted to
so no he's not leaving such a beautiful
situation but ak has seen me when i was
doubtful
of information ak has seen me when it
was me against the company aks see me
when it was me against tim me against
the desk
he's able to read the [ __ ] tea leaves
man and that's an important piece
nowadays button said there's
there's a mutual respect between himself
and academics as for rory button claimed
that a relationship was altered
after rory took issue with button still
having contact with academics
button who said he doesn't know
academics to be a liar
also noted that he has suspicions of
rory having sent people to academics
home
in one clip from the interview embedded
below button says he
he's fired rory rory feels like he has
so many options here
somehow he still feels like he's running
the show and he still feels like he has
choices and options he still feels like
he's entitled to more
rory you are in breach of your contract
and from this point forward you are
fired and you are not
welcome back but in around 22 minutes
in also spoke on a recent podcast in
which rory and maul returned to the show
after a break
that episode was important according to
bun because he had a six
week window to speak to the audience and
he felt that it was important for rory
and maul to have a chance to say what
they wanted to say
that's the stuff i'd be trying to
explain to the suits the creative on uh
so deeper into the new episode in
question around 1 hour and 27 minutes
in but and spoke on the importance of
chemistry's work
that's the stuff that i'd be trying to
explain to the suits the creators
understand chemistry
i wanted to say them yo dawg i don't i
don't know what's going on right now but
the chemistry
ain't there and he just goes on
and he's basically just saying then like
you're kind of like overstepping your
boundaries
you know like you kind of just don't
know what your place is or something
like that yeah so i don't know what
their relationship is per se i
personally have never had a dealing with
people whereas ever went bad like that
everybody felt that it was mutually
respectful right let's just say like
this if this podcast was making
a handsome amount of money of course
these guys are getting checks whenever
they come in
everybody would jk news when jk and you
started making money
in the beginning nobody was getting
checks you know why because there was no
money there
yeah nobody did yeah that makes sense
but then when we all got that deal
joe and bart took us all to the room and
they gave us a fat check dude it was
ridiculous yeah like i was like what the
[ __ ] is this yeah because it was
it was it was a lot they take care of
their people yeah everybody who comes on
jk news they walk away with a check
because the company makes money
and they and they get it and nobody
walks away with the unfair pay
you know your boy working on that
you know your boy working out we got
[ __ ] knit socks and we have drinks
that's
what i got right now that's what we have
to offer and it's fire bro yeah and it's
fire
yeah you know and so like yeah i
understand if they weren't getting paid
but yeah of course but yeah this guy is
rory mall
who are they i don't know what do they
do i was just look i was doing some
research on them no shots on them
but it's like one of them i think is a
music producer
and then the other guy i don't know what
he does or whatever
but at the same time it's like
you can't bite the hand that feeds you
sometimes also too aren't you guys
friends
yeah aren't you friends and also you're
getting paid what the [ __ ] is the issue
bro
and when you shut up and when you and
here's the thing too this is what
happens agreed right
right yeah when they came money always
[ __ ] things up
because if it was like that you truly
valued who you were on that podcast
like you knew who you were before you
stepped into that room say hey
joe i know my value i know i can make
this [ __ ] show popping with all three
of us
if we do continue this forward is it
possible or do you think that i would
like
a piece of this yeah right but instead
you waited to see like oh
is this show going to be popping let's
see what's up yeah and then it became
really pop and became very lucrative you
were getting a paycheck and then you go
wait now i deserve a piece of this but
you never thought about that before when
your value wasn't that big before joe
budden put you put you right right
exactly and that's where it becomes very
problematic also too
stop coming up with your hands out like
this that's how i feel anyways
yeah making your own bread bro bro
what's your own business you can always
do something else and use your brand and
make it bigger you can
take this paycheck that joe is giving
you and the clout
and then go start your own podcast aside
from him do other [ __ ] and blow your
[ __ ] up yeah because you had that power
exactly it's there like don't don't wait
for joe budden to keep giving you these
[ __ ] handouts
you're worth more than that according to
you you're worth more than that yeah if
that's true put your money where your
mouth is yeah
get that [ __ ] paycheck that joe's
getting you take that clout open
something else
go buy some bitcoin just make it work do
what you got to do
yeah yeah i personally i mean like i
said we're reading on i'm reading this
stuff from the outside from what he's
saying to them
they're friends so i don't know how they
talk to each other they're going at it
like that
doesn't seem like you guys are friends
yeah right so it sounds weird yeah
it does sound like they're out of line
though i mean i like i said i don't know
the the context like everything that's
going on but if it's just this then it
sounds like joe budden's on the right
for sure
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you getting
paid yeah when he fronts all the money
for
studio time yeah why would you like are
you putting in on that did you build
this
are you are you putting up you know the
money for the rent where you guys do
your studio right yeah
so he brought all the eyes exactly like
and it's also like
what was who were you before you hopped
on are you bringing on guests
what is your value yeah yeah like what
do you do besides
come in and talk for an hour exactly
because that's the easy part
yo you tell anyone to show up and just
talk for a couple hours and they're
going to pay you money
that's fine but what else are you doing
to provide value besides the actual
content
if you're getting paid for your time to
produce and and do content that's one
thing
but you ha i feel like to be involved in
the
the inner workings of getting the money
like and
asking for a bigger payday you have to
be doing more than just showing up it's
like this right
and i'll put it to you like this when
when i get hired to do an acting job do
i say hey i got
[ __ ] half a million followers in this
i need a piece of this movie
yeah you should try that that's probably
a good
auditioning you know who might do that
will smith my people will do that yeah
because they know
but also they're making a movie for will
smith exactly yeah because
if i'm playing a role you give me a
check i do my job
and i know that you guys have to deal
with everything else yeah and then i
walk away yeah right
like yeah is it fair not it kind of is
and depending how you look at it right
yeah like that's like
when people get mad at like jake paul
for making all this money for
for doing boxing while all these other
fighters are not getting
their due but it's also like he's
bringing the eyes
yeah bringing the people as much as you
like this guy or not
he's bringing eyes to him and it's
undeniable how much attention he grabs
yeah so at the end of the day it's like
you got to provide something
yeah i don't know man i just don't like
it when money gets [ __ ] up
with friends especially if you're
getting paid that's the
and this i'm pretty sure they're not
getting paid getting paid pennies i
don't know the actual logistics
but they're definitely not getting
they're getting like 300 bucks an
episode or something
if you're making seven figures on your
podcast you better not be paying them
300 bucks a [ __ ] episode yeah yeah
because that's a little too high yeah
and if they're shooting like
an episode a week it's like dude i'm
making seven [ __ ] figures it's like
dude you guys are gonna walk away with
at least six seven grand a month
something seven yeah i don't know what
it is
especially if they're the only people
they don't bring on guests they're the
only ones doing the podcast if the
podcast is fire
you know yeah like that's what matters
at the end of the day is the content
right like yeah that matters first
but then the other [ __ ] that comes along
with it is
it's very secondary you know let me tell
you something man this
there's no producers for this yeah i get
up i hit this button i set up the camera
i hit this button
i had to paint this room myself
it was [ __ ] rough you're like you
guys have a producer like dude every
time i go on a podcast
they have a producer there's somebody
feeding them articles topics
wow i'm like what the [ __ ] is going on
yeah
and they're like hey so who produces
your stuff i'm like you're looking at it
i'm producing this stuff they go
everybody has a producer i'm the only
one without a producer dude wow
yeah yeah we gotta get your producer i
don't even have an editor everybody at
least is an editor or producer or
something i don't do everything you edit
everything yeah
audio still ain't making money yeah
click on those ads every now and then
you know when i get those sponsored ads
like you guys have to click on
sign up for these trials man i [ __ ] with
these companies help us out
i need to give them a chat magic spoon
yeah i mean what else people are like
hey man yeah people are like
it's like yo man david down earth he
don't buy it he don't buy dope [ __ ] it's
cause i can't
it's not a life choice bro i'll be
living [ __ ] low-key
i save up my little pennies and then i
you know get dividends from businesses
and i reopen businesses because i don't
got it like that dude
[ __ ] you but just wait bro people really
think that ballin is so funny dude
that's [ __ ] hilarious [ __ ] yeah you
guys are [ __ ] crazy
they've been balling kind of low-key in
his own way and [ __ ] hey he bought us
you know he got his own kettlebell
yeah i got the ball you've got about the
bowflex got a ball different weights
you know yeah you got the balls out
there your slimes yeah you got a couple
slam balls
those ain't cheap yeah i got those on
facebook marketplace really cheap
kicking the walls yeah i know ladies
fall not picking them up
okay so anyways guys don't pick up my
shave like that bro
uh let's uh myself
it that's all it is yeah i mean hey man
that's like what is this dude
hey don't don't use uh [ __ ] people's
real plight for your personal [ __ ]
if somebody disses you go ahead and
handle that [ __ ] tony hitchcliff stop
saying the word cheat don't say [ __ ]
you don't say in the first sentence
especially when you look like you're a
part of the aryan brotherhood you're not
gonna
you're not gonna get a pass on that
[ __ ] what's wrong with you dude
that's wow that's a hot one yeah weird
dude your next set
drop an bomb in the first one yeah let's
see what happens and then walk off stage
just say that and then leave
yeah yeah and then just chill yeah
[Laughter]
yeah well guys that wraps up this
episode you can find nick at nick the
ear and you can find
pat at patrick.tt.org yeah
and we will see you all next time yes
peace